The Joe Rogan Experience we had a fun
few weeks
yeah like the craziest it's been pretty
crazy yeah this past weekend was bananas
though so we do this show in Columbus
Ohio
uh Dave Chappelle comes surprises the
audience goes on stage and it's probably
the greatest round of applause I've ever
seen anyone get in my life not probably
definitely 100 Ohio Zone Dave Chappelle
in the main Arena of the main city of
Ohio in the shots oh we can play on the
big screen
[Applause]
foreign
now listen how long this goes
and this is a standing ovation the
standing ovation literally goes on for a
minute foreign
[Applause]
how Wild is that
that was that was amazing it's so cool
and it's like the it's like it almost in
a weird way makes me happy that the
lockdowns and all that happened because
it made something like that that much
crazier like it's like you re I feel
like people really appreciate live
spontaneous Insanity now more than ever
yes for sure they they well it was just
an awesome moment you know it was just a
great moment yeah he just decides to
roll in and come up and then we all went
to Vegas so then we all went to see the
Canelo Alvarez fight you and I also saw
Abu Dhabi so we saw Gordon Ryan dominate
at Abu Dhabi and then we went to see two
of the craziest [ __ ] UFC fights I've
ever seen yeah Gregory Rodriguez and uh
which was a crazy fight that went back
and forth until Rodriguez caught him and
Rodriguez had the worst cut I've ever
seen in my life and then Sonya dong the
guy who fights after him against Corey
sandhagen also has a horrific cut
and there was a massive cut in the fight
just before that with uh Feely and he
had blood all over him just from having
choking out the other guy that was on
top of him bleeding there was blood the
hole the whole time yeah it was a wild
three fight so that's right we saw that
fight too we saw the last round of that
yeah
that cut that Rodriguez had was
absolutely insane insane
the thing about that experience though I
think we did it in the wrong order
I think uh it should have like Abu Dhabi
was amazing Abu Dhabi could kind of put
anywhere but you you kind of have to put
boxing before MMA or it ruins boxing for
you totally it just doesn't feel the
same right it's just it's it's great
don't get me wrong I'm a boxing fan I
was super happy to be there it was a
wild fight but it's just not not the
same yeah it's like getting a hand job
after a gangbang
it's like I didn't really need that I
sort of had that earlier but better
UFC is just so Advanced the other thing
that boxing does is they play the
national anthems they played three
national anthems
and it's like good Lord so they play the
kha'zix down national anthem and then
the dude says you know go Triple G and
everybody's like [ __ ] you this is
Mexican Independence weekend right yeah
and then um then they play the uh
Mexican national anthem everybody goes
crazy and they sing along which is
pretty dope because like when you're a
place that's that big and it's all like
I mean it had to be at least half
Mexicans oh that's yeah at least 70 yeah
whatever the number was yeah so when
these songs were playing like when
Canelo has his walk out song which is
also in Spanish or when there's they're
singing the Mexican Independence Day
song they're singing this song the
Mexican national anthem rather they're
singing this song in Spanish all
together so there's thousands of people
singing along yeah before the fight
started I saw in this stands there was
like 30 or 40 seats that were blocked
off that were just completely empty in
this sea of humans and I'm like the
performer in me is like why would they
lose that many seats why would they
possibly where are those people what bus
didn't make it here exact same thing you
saw it I thought they maybe could get
burned by the fireworks right that was
my first yeah and then it's canelo's
entrance and the lights go off pop back
on and there's a whole Marriott a full
band playing for Canelo as he comes out
I legitimately thought that that was
probably where the fireworks were and
people could get [ __ ] up by those
fireworks
yeah
because you know people have been [ __ ]
up by fireworks in uh fight entrances
before pretty bad to the point where
they got Burns all over their body and
they they couldn't fight I know that
happened in Pride
and pride the dude got really cooked he
was a Brazilian guy
I don't remember his name but he was an
early early Pioneer of MMA and he was
fighting in in Pride and he got
torched by the fireworks you out of here
oh yeah this is the one from the fight
we just saw this is the uh that's the
mariachi band see I thought those seats
behind them were like people could get
hit with those fireworks
Maybe
because you see how they blew them off
they blow off a lot of all that [ __ ] I
was like you can't sit under that
yeah it would have been an obstructed
view from that screen yeah it's not like
that wasn't a sold out fight that was
right sold out fight and so Chappelle
and I were in the third row which was
amazing we were like right there and
then this guy comes over and says you
guys have to move these tickets are uh
are not yours and uh and and Dave goes
I'm Dave Chappelle I'm not moving
anywhere
that's he's wearing sunglasses he's the
coolest guy that's ever lived and so the
guy comes back and said these seats are
actually for Travis Scott but we want to
put you on the Ring Side and Dave and I
look at each other we're like okay and
so they take us from the third row to
the no row like it's not even a row
you're you're [ __ ] right there dude
we're sitting like where the officials
sit it was incredible they were right
there it was really good and we saw the
last like I think six rounds like that
something like that but it was uh it was
a good fight it was a really good fight
I mean Canal Alvarez is a bad
[ __ ] you know and Triple G tried
to turn it on at the end he just didn't
have enough to take the decision but it
was still a good fight and you got to
realize that Triple G is 40 years old
too
that's so old for a world-class boxer
there's only a few guys have been able
to pull that off like Bernard Hopkins
and Archie Moore back in the day was an
older guy who's a really good
Dwight Muhammad kawi he fought well into
his 40s it's just like some of these
guys they they just one day the wheels
fall off
you know might be your 36 maybe you're
37 38 Just One Day the wheels fall off
like uh ADCC everyone was so young like
yeah baby shark
well how about rutolo
19 years old and wins 80cc youngest guy
ever that kid is wild he and his brother
are so good those guys are so good and
they're 19. it's incredible there were
some times where it looked like he was
in trouble I mean
and to
Vienna these guys just they make it look
so easy it looks like they're just
rolling around like it's an accident
that's Gordon Gordon makes it look easy
those guys are moving like ninjas right
they have a totally different kind of
style Gordon is just like he just puts
poison on people yeah he's just grabs
and puts poison on them they're [ __ ]
it's some like they're mentally
compromised it seems like like they are
all buying into the hype of him
no
no no they just realized he's that good
so they're scared but every every when I
say scared I don't mean terrified what I
mean is like they feel the moment right
every one of those world-class Fighters
that that goes up against another
world-class fighter at that moment
when the match is about to start and
everything's on the line they have no
idea who's gonna win they all have like
a wild feeling of anticipation but with
Gordon they have it worse because no
one's beating him he's just running
through everybody and he's talking [ __ ]
and he's like a giant good-looking guy
he's a giant good-looking guy who talks
[ __ ] look at him I mean look at that guy
I mean if that wasn't a real person if
you said to me is that CGI or is that a
real person
I'd say that's CGI man nobody looks like
that unless he's a bodybuilder why would
he look that good and he's cool and
funny
said that he called his mom before the
tournament and told her that he won
but the thing is it's like there's no
one like him he's 27 years old and he's
widely accepted as the greatest of all
time already
he hasn't been beaten in his last
50-something matches and he gets so
bored with it that he literally writes
down on a piece of paper how he's gonna
strangle them I'm gonna get a person
like this I'm gonna get this guy a
triangle I'm gonna get this guy in a
mounted triangle I'm gonna just I'm
gonna do whatever I want yeah he told me
before that fight he's like I'm gonna
give him a single leg and let him take
me down oh yeah that was the Nikki
Rodriguez fight yeah and he did yeah
well they were really good training
Partners Nikki Rod is a beast too that
that whole thing was wild man to watch
how good the level of Jiu Jitsu is now
it's so exciting
it's so exciting because these guys are
the top of the food chain guys and then
they're strangling each other and so
it's not just that like a top of the
food chain Jiu Jitsu guy can go against
a regular person and use it because
they're using it on each other the best
of the best guys are using it on each
other and they're tapping each other
ha
you know and Gordon Brian got galvao's
back and and tapped him it's like oh
that's a crazy moment man that is a
[ __ ] passing of the torch if you're
ever gonna see one
I mean even when he did it he he didn't
even have a fully locked in rear naked
choke he just had the forearm across and
he was I'm sure he had tremendous
leverage but it's not as strong as he
could have gotten and if he got the full
you know grab a hold of the biceps and
strangle if you watch it again Watch how
he Taps him with it
like this that's I'm sure strong
look see how he's got his like arm on
his forearm that's for sure ridiculous
and sucks a thousand dicks but it's not
as hard as he could do it if Gordon went
all the way over
and he but what he's doing here is also
he's trapping the right arm so he can't
really defend himself
and he's got the other arm trapped in
his legs it's really brilliant if you
look at it it looks like his right hand
is like loose too it doesn't even look
like he's pulling and look at that it's
sliding down yeah well you see what he's
doing what he did was he traps his left
arm with his left leg and then he traps
his right arm with his left arm so he's
one arm strangling him with the
guillotine and gave out literally can't
defend so what I'm saying is I'm not
saying it's like it's not an awesome way
to tap somebody it certainly is but
that's not the hardest he could do it
the fact that he can tap world champions
with a a technique that is utilizing you
know a
a a small percentage of the power that
he would get if he fully locked and
clamped down on the head or if he got a
Gable grip I mean it's wild
it's a one-armed rear naked strangle is
what it is it's crazy
yeah to do that on a world champion who
can take a lot of pain yeah dude he's
he's such a bad [ __ ] Gordon is
the [ __ ] man it's crazy to see
anybody that good at anything at
anything yeah at anything it's like
watching a ball roll downhill it's like
he's eventually going to get him yeah
well that's that's what they always said
about Hickson in his prime too it was a
really similar kind of uh feeling that
everybody had like you could just
couldn't keep up the Rhythm eventually
he's gonna get you like everybody who
rolled with Hixson had the same same
statement they would all say the same
thing they would be like he's the best
he's the best and that's what that's
what they say about Gordon yeah it's
like there's these guys in sports for
whatever reason man they have this
[ __ ] extra gear and they could put in
more focus and more dedication and more
energy and more intelligence and they
could formulate better strategies and
they're more effective with their time
management and they don't [ __ ]
themselves up in in their personal lives
so that their lives filled with chaos
and they have all these distractions if
they can if it's really rare that you
find someone that can do what that guy's
doing